now a category four storm with sustained
winds in excess of 230 kilometers per
hour Hurricane Dorian is edging closer
to the US as southeast coast in Florida
a state of emergency has been declared
in dozens of counties as people bought
up their homes fuel their cars and brace
themselves in case the hurricane makes
landfall after twelve residents of a
nursing home died from heat exhaustion
during hurricane her in 2017 the states
enacted strict guidelines for Florida's
many assisted living facilities
hurricane durian is being seen as a
vital test for the new laws we're
hopeful that this generator will be Bay
Oaks CEO Catherine Kastner installed a
state-of-the-art generator says the care
industry is much better prepared I think
today given the devastating loss of so
many lives that everybody is very keen
to avoid that at all costs o resident
Martin Caidin has lived through
hurricanes before and tells us he feels
safe as durian lingers of the East Coast
this building is very secure I know
we're very close to the bay but we're
elevated slightly Dorian's projected
path continues to change residents of
the Bahamas are under serious threat as
they brace for impact on Sunday the
storm may not make a direct hit on
Florida that the governor is warning
against complacency if it bumps further
east that obviously is positive if it
bumps just a little west then you're
looking at really really significant
impacts and so don't make any
assumptions remain vigilant and be
prepared
the key phrase now is cone of
uncertainty which places Florida Georgia
and the Carolinas in the potential path
of hurricane Dorian forecasters and
residents are watching closely this
remains a powerful storm with an
unpredictable path and people are
preparing for the worst and hoping that
Dorian skirts the East Coast sparing
millions from what's being described as
a
to storm the states in the potential
path of durian have been hit many times
before all remain vigilant all are
prepared now it's a case of watching a
slowly moving storm that seems to be
only getting stronger as it tracks
through the warm waters of the Atlantic
the Gallacher al jazeera Miami Florida